♪ ♪
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, JUST TWO
HOURS, ONE MINUTE UNTIL MY BOOK
"LIVE FREE OR DIE: AMERICA ON
THE BRINK" IS FINALLY OUT.
THANK YOU, YOU ALREADY MADE IT
NUMBER ONE NONFICTION ON
Amazon.com.
BY THE WAY, IT’S NOW DISCOUNTED
THERE ON Amazon.com, 34%.
I DON’T KNOW WHO DECIDED THAT
BUT I’M HAPPY, THAT’S GOOD
BECAUSE I WANT TO GET THE
MESSAGE OUT, FIRST BOOK IN TEN
YEARS.
WE HAVE A LIST OF EVENTS WE LOVE
TO INVITE YOU TO FOR THE BOOK,
WE’D LOVE TO HAVE YOU
PARTICIPATE IN.
AGAIN, NUMBER ONE, AMAZON THANKS
TO YOU.
WE ALSO HAVE OUR ELECTION
INTERACTIVE MAP.
Hannity.com.
WINDOWS EARLY EARLY VOTING START
IN YOUR STATE?
WHAT ABOUT ABSENTEE VOTING?
ALL HANDS ON DECK MOMENT FOR THE
COUNTRY.
I WILL BE ON "FOX & FRIENDS"
TOMORROW, LET NOT YOUR HEART BE
TROUBLED BECAUSE I’M ABOUT TO
GET BEATEN UP BY LAURA INGRAHAM
SO MY HEART HAS TO BE TROUBLED.
>> Laura: ARE YOU READY?
ARE YOU READY?
>> Sean: THAT’S THE WAY TO
START AN INTERVIEW.
OH, MAN.
>> Laura: YOU THINK GOING ON
"THE VIEW" IS DIFFICULT.
BUT YOU ARE KIND OF PALS WITH
BEHAR AND THE CREW.
>> Sean: CAN I TELL YOU A
QUICK, FUNNY STORY IF YOU’RE
INTERESTED?
LAST TIME I WAS ON "THE VIEW,"
IT BECAME IN HONOR OF ADAM
SCHIFF, A B-17 SHOW AND BARBARA,
GOD BLESS HER, COULDN’T STOP IT.
HARD-HITTING NEWS SHOW, IT’S TOO
TOUGH.
>> Laura: I REMEMBER ONCE,
BEHAR, AND SHE’S KIND OF FUNNY.
SHE IS AN OUTRAGEOUS LIBERAL BUT
SHE’S FUNNY AND SHE SAYS "LAURA,
BARBRA STREISAND IS A VERY
PATRIOTIC PERSON, LAURA, STOP
CRITICIZING BARBRA STREISAND.
BECAUSE I WROTE THAT BOOK "SHUT
UP AND SING," IT WAS VERY
UPSETTING.
>> Sean: IT SOUNDS LIKE "WE
ARE NEW YORKERS AND WE ARE
PREPARED."
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT, WE’VE GOT
TO TALK NEW YORK BECAUSE IN A
MOMENT I AM GOING TO EXCLUSIVELY
INTERVIEWING MIKE PENCE.
HE’S FOLLOWING YOU AND GIVEN THE
LEFT’S ATTEMPTS TO KEEP KIDS OUT
OF SCHOOL, TRYING TO KEEP THEM
OUT OF INDEPENDENT AND PRIVATE
SCHOOLS IN THE MONTGOMERY COUNTY
SUBURB OF D.C. SO I’M GOING TO
GET TO THAT BUT WE HAVE TO GET
TO YOUR BOOK AND I CAN’T BELIEVE
YOU ONLY HIT NUMBER ONE, THAT IS
SO LAME.
IS IT OUT IN TWO HOURS?
JUST TWO HOURS?
>> Sean: ONE HOUR AND TO BE
EXACT, 58 MINUTES.
>> Laura: HOW DO YOU ARRANGE
TO BE NUMBER ONE, IS THAT JUST
PREORDERS?
DO YOU BUY YOUR OWN BOOK?
>> Sean: NO, I AM NOT INVOLVED
IN THE SELLING, I DO KNOW,
BECAUSE OF COVID, WE KNEW THINGS
WERE GOING TO BE DIFFERENT.
WE PUT UP ALL THESE EVENTS.
I HAVE ASSIGNED, IF I TOLD YOU
HOW MANY YOU WOULDN’T BELIEVE ME
ME.
>> Laura: STOP BRAGGING.
>> Sean: I WOULD NORMALLY GO
ON A BOOK TOUR.
>> Laura: I HAVE A QUESTION,
WHEN YOU DO SIGNING, BECAUSE OF
ALL YOUR MIXED MARTIAL ARTS, DO
YOU FLEX WHEN YOU SIGN?
>> Sean: SERIOUSLY.
YOU ARE JUST LIKE MY THREE OLDER
SISTERS, YOU JUST LIKE TO
TORTURE ME.
>> Laura: NO, I’M SERIOUS, I’M
SO PROUD OF YOU BECAUSE YOU
HAVEN’T HAD A BOOK IN A WHILE.
>> Sean: TEN YEARS.
>> Laura: IT’S FLYING OFF THE
SHELVES OF COURSE AND IT’S GOING
TO BE NUMBER ONE IN EVERY
CATEGORY.
>> Sean: I HATE WRITING BOOKS,
IT’S TOO HARD.
>> Laura: TAKES A LOT OF TIME.
I WANT TO GET TO SOME SERIOUS
QUESTIONS.
THREE MONTHS, WE HAVE THE
ELECTION.
AND THINGS SEEM TO BE SHIFTING,
I THINK, INTO TRUMP’S DIRECTION.
WHO KNOWS WHAT THE POLLS ARE
SAYING.
IS IT THE RIOTS THAT’S MOVING
MIDDLE AMERICA BACK TOWARD TRUMP
TRUMP?
THE SCHOOL ISSUE OR ALL OF THE
ABOVE?
WHAT IS IT?
>> Sean: IT’S A GREAT QUESTION
AND I WILL TRY TO BE VERY QUICK
WITH MY ANSWERS WHICH IS HARD
FOR ME.
I THINK IT’S A COMBINATION OF
WOW, THE LEFT HAS EMBRACED
ANARCHY, THEY ARE NOT SUPPORTING
SAFETY AND SECURITY, LAW AND
ORDER.
OBAMA’S SPEECH, COULD IT GET ANY
MORE DIVISIVE THAN LAST WEEK?
JOE BIDEN, AND I THINK THIS IS A
SIGN OF PURE WEAKNESS, THAT HAD
TO SHORE UP HIS OWN BASE BECAUSE
HE WASN’T CONFIDENT BERNIE’S
FOLLOWERS WOULD VOTE FOR HIM.
SO HE LITERALLY, LIKE HE ALWAYS
DOES, PLAGIARIZED BOLSHEVIK
BERNIE’S ECONOMIC AGENDA.
HIS GUNS, THE GUY WHO WANTS TO
CONFISCATE GUNS.
I WOULD ARGUE, LAURA, AND I
STARTED THIS PROJECT ABOUT A
YEAR AGO THINKING THAT THIS WAS
GOING TO BE THE MOMENT, I REALLY
DID.
I BELIEVE THAT WHERE IT WAS
GOING TO BE THE BIGGEST CHOICE
ELECTION AND SO MUCH WAS AT
STAKE AND I SWORE TEN YEARS AGO
I WOULDN’T WRITE ANOTHER BOOK
BUT I NEEDED TO GET IT DOWN, I
CAN’T GET IT ALL OUT WITH A
HISTORY I WANT TO GIVE, IT’S
EVEN WORSE THAN I THOUGHT IT
WOULD BE.
BECAUSE WHEN DO WE EVER SEE A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE, WE
USUALLY SEE CANDIDATES GO TO THE
BASE TO GET A NOMINATION, MOVED
TO THE CENTER IN A GENERAL
ELECTION.
TWO EXCEPTIONS TO THAT RULE
WOULD BE RONALD REAGAN AND
DONALD J. TRUMP.
DONALD J. TRUMP IS PREDICTABLE,
HE KEPT ALL HIS PROMISES THAT HE
MADE AND HE NEVER CHANGED.
YOU AND I CAN VOUCH FOR THIS
CONSERVATIVE GOVERNANCE WHEN SO
MANY OF OUR FELLOW CONSERVATIVES
IT NEVER HAPPENED.
>> Laura: THEY DITCHED THEM.
I’M ABOUT TO TALK TO THE
VICE PRESIDENT SO I HAVE TO ASK
YOU, THE TOP CONTENDER.
>> Sean: HE IS MORE IMPORTANT,
I AGREE.
>> Laura: HE DOESN’T HAVE THE
NUMBER ONE BOOK BUT HE IS THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
VICE PRESIDENTIAL CONTENDER,
KAMALA HARRIS, SUSAN RICE,
COMMIE KAREN BASS, TAMMY
DUCKWORTH, ELIZABETH WARREN.
OF ALL OF THESE CONTENDERS, WHO
WOULD BE THE WORST FOR
PRESERVING OUR CIVIL LIBERTIES
THAT ARE UNDER ASSAULT RIGHT NOW
NOW?
>> Sean: ONE OBSERVATION
FIRST, THAT IS THAT
HISTORICALLY, VICE PRESIDENTIAL
SELECTIONS ARE NOT, IT’S USUALLY
DO NO HARM, THAT’S WHAT YOU WANT
IN A VICE PRESIDENTIAL
SELECTION.
PEOPLE PICK THE TOP OF THE
TICKET.
THE ONE THING I WOULD ARGUE,
EVERYBODY IN THIS MODERN EXTREME
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PARTY HAS
IS THAT A RADICAL LEFT, THEY ALL
HAVE THAT IN COMMON.
AND, WHICH FITS INTO WHAT JOE
HAS DONE AND I DON’T KNOW HOW
YOU ALLOW ALL THESE LIBERAL
CITIES THAT CAN’T RESTORE
"LAW & ORDER"," THAT...
I DON’T SEE ONE PERSON THAT IS
REALLY ON IDEOLOGY THAT
DIFFERENT.
THEY ARE ALL FAR LEFT.
ALL FAR LEFT.
>> Laura: I THINK, LOOK, IT’S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT YOU WROTE
THIS BOOK AT THIS TIME,
EVERYBODY GO OUT AND GET IT.
"LIVE FREE OR DIE," THAT IS WHY
OUR COUNTRY IS SPECIAL.
>> Sean: EVEN THOUGH YOU ARE
LIKE MY THREE OLDER SISTERS YOU
ARE A DEAR FRIEND, I APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT.
THE SUPPORT OF MY FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES MEANS MORE THAN
ANYTHING AND WE CAN’T DO THIS,
WE TALK ABOUT THIS A LOT, THIS
WONDERFUL, LOYAL SUPPORTIVE
AUDIENCE, THEY GIVE US THE
SCREEN, THEY GIVE US OUR RADIO
SHOWS, AND THEY ARE MAKING IT
POSSIBLE THAT I HAVE A
FIVE-ALARM FIRE IN MY HEAD AND
MY HEART AND MY SOUL, IF THESE
POLICIES ARE ENACTED IT WILL BE
A DISASTER FOR THE COUNTRY IN IN
THE WORLD.
>> Laura: SUFFERING, REAL
SUFFERING.
CONGRATS ON THE BOOK.